[Music]
yes
i'm back i know you got something else i
know you got to have something good
you got a few minutes i got a minute or
two okay
i want to spend just a few minutes
talking about
why science is hard okay so
you spend your whole life trying to get
people to get into science
this morning you wake up and you go you
know what forget all that
let's just tell them the truth let's
tell them
science is hard and drive them where
they belong
well i don't i don't think you're going
to surprise anybody with science is hard
but hard in a way that maybe you hadn't
fully appreciated
okay now that okay once again you've
been treated
you've intrigued me all right now you've
intrigued me in the physical sciences
especially physics astrophysics this
sort of thing
you need a tandem background in math and
many people don't like math
so for them science might be hard simply
because it has math
right so but i'm gonna i'm gonna go
someplace completely different
oh okay oh okay now i'm now i'm
really i'll tell you why it's hard
because guess what
the thing you just said was enough for
me
okay you had me at
math okay all right so here's why
okay and this is going to be
storytelling
excellent storytelling all right
so back in the 1700s late 1700s there
was an astronomer named william herschel
uh he was wealthy you know had access to
great telescopes
and he liked looking up herschel
personally all right um he
discovered an object that moved
against the background stars okay
cool and people have discovered such
objects before they were all comets
okay all right if something's moving and
it's a comet
so he kept studying it and he and if you
read his research papers it was
odd comet that this is it's not showing
any fuzz
that's a peculiar comment i wonder when
it will start showing fuzz
and he goes on and on and on about this
account of an
unusual comet
he discovered the planet uranus
oh wow and you know why he was in denial
because no one had discovered a planet
before
right right it was an act without
precedent
all right all the known planets mercury
venus
mars jupiter and saturn these are the
planets in the
sky of the earth all of them were
known since the ancients and they're
bright enough cavemen would have seen it
so no one had to that was they were not
from the act any act of discovery
because they're all brighter than the
naked eye limit in the nighttime sky
so uranus was the first planet
to be discovered and it required a
telescope
and he was in denial of it because it
had no precedent so
first the scientist is challenged by
discovering something for which there is
no precedent
hmm what do you call it how do you think
about it
what do you he didn't say oh i
discovered a new plan he said i
discovered a weird comet
right so he discovers it he realizes
it's a new planet this is big news
international news and what do you do oh
he's a brit
uh by this is late 1700's so there's
king
george this is the same king george of
the
declaration of independence to whom it
was written right
okay yes and so
he named it after the king
ah so for and i have textbooks from this
period of time after that planet was
named but before it got renamed
for a while there the enumeration of
planets was mercury venus earth
mars jupiter saturn and george
stop it serious come on
you want to keep the king happy the man
you know you can't bl don't blame
right listen you can't piss off the king
i saw him i saw hamilton
i saw hamilton i know you don't want to
mess with king george
all right let's have this it's the same
king right
okay so that lasted a few decades until
clearer heads prevailed it's in a waiter
it's a planet and how are the previous
ones named well they have roman name
roman gods right uranus is kind of both
greek and roman
so there it is so it got named damn
that is unfortunate okay
do you want it you wanted a planet
george i swear to god it would be so
great we are
launching a probe to planet george
or it would be fun it would approach to
freddy you know just your name
no because maybe that would have started
a precedent where you just start naming
stuff like you know what i mean
and comets get named after people like
you were like haley haley's comments
exactly okay all right so now here we go
i'm not done yet go ahead so
you track the orbit of uranus
and you find out it's not following
newton's
laws of gravity and newton's laws have
been known for
100 years by then okay and so
people said hmm maybe we found the outer
limits
of where newton's gravity applies ah
because it worked between earth and the
moon earth and the sun
the moons of jupiter everything that was
orbiting somebody else that we observed
that newton's laws were bang on but
let's go
farther out in the solar system here we
are at the farthest most planet
uranus and it's deviating from where
newton's law is predicted
so you say all right do we need a new
law of gravity
no newton's been working pretty well
lately
a new one to extend newton's laws
because it doesn't apply that far out
maybe it
only works in our own solar system you
don't know this in advance
okay people have to figure this out so
they say
all right um maybe newton's laws do
apply
at uranus but there's another planet out
there
that we haven't discovered yet that's
tugging on it and we didn't put that in
the equation
so so maybe uranus
newton's laws are correct and uranus is
being touched
by yet another planet
so here we have a situation where all
right
if there's another planet how are we
going to figure out where it is
right this is an extremely difficult
math problem
it's one thing to have an object invoke
newton's law of gravity and say here's
the strength of gravity at this distance
from you
okay it's different to say
here i am responding to a force of
gravity out there and i don't know how
strong it is and i don't know where it
is
so it's a mathematical inversion problem
of that gravity
of the gravitational setup and so two
brilliant mathematicians took their to
took their genius to this
and one of them is is
french right and another guy named uh
john couch adams
okay and i think he was a brit
and so brilliant mathematicians they did
this inversion problem and le verrier
got there first
and he said hmm if newton's laws apply
and there's something tugging on
it it should be a an object over here in
this part of the sky
okay so he he he got the message to the
berlin observatory
and there's a guy named johann gal who
the night he the day he received that
note
that night he looked where he was
supposed to and found
the planet neptune holy crap
it was just a triumph of newton's laws
of gravity
a triumph of mathematics a triumph of
international
communication and cooperation and there
it was
planet that's amazing totally amazing
and it's a beautiful story too it's
beautiful all right so now
we have planet neptune and all right
we're good pat ourselves on the shoulder
then you say
all right so something's happening with
neptune something's happening
neptune and also parts of uranus were
not
collectively were not following newton's
laws precisely
so well we've been down that road before
right come on we even know what's going
on
time for another trial time for another
planet okay
exactly so let's perform the math it's a
planet x
okay famous planet x so let's do the
inversion problem and look over there
nope no planet okay maybe i didn't do
that right let's look over there nope
no planet so we're right now up into the
late 1800s
early 1900s and percival
of the new england lowells around who
was uh
not to be not to be confused with the
north carolina rules
the personal uh
uh he built a telescope put it on a
mountaintop in arizona where there
hardly any cloud so he knew what he was
doing
and he um he
said i'm gonna find planet x okay
except he died before that happened but
by fortunately he hired someone
who took on this task and that was
clyde tombaugh a young amateur
astronomer
who was hired to say all right forget
this inversion math problem looking in
spots in the sky
let's just look at the whole damn sky
okay let's do let's just be systematic
about that
so clyde tombaugh systematically
photograph
the entire sky in the plane of the solar
system
okay where you find all the other
planets he just just
systematically photographed and did it
twice
so you do it twice so that you compare
the two and if something moved it it
shifts from one picture to the next
right because i got something okay
that's so cool they still do that today
they don't
do that today they do yeah computers but
we still do that today right
and with the human eye brain combination
is very good at noting noticing
something different
all right between the pictures i have a
whole book of those puzzles
excellent excellent so much fun
excellent so so
you still haven't grown up right
yeah you know you know what's the chuck
put down the where's waldo books
put it down away from the book
[Laughter]
so go ahead so he does this and so they
find a lot of things in this survey
they found asteroids they found what
okay
and then then 1930
there's the announcement we have found
planet x
and it got to be called pluto clyde
tombow in 1930 discovered pluto
wow all right so now the new york times
headline said planet x found we expect
it to be
the size of the earth because that's how
much mass it would need
to jiggle on on neptune on uranus and
neptune okay
all right so then over the years however
people kept trying to measure the size
of pluto
and no it's not as big as you thought no
it's not as massive as you thought
no it's even smaller than that no it's
even smaller than that in fact
over the decades the estimated size of
pluto kept getting smaller and smaller
and smaller
someone created a chart to see if we
keep this up pluto will disappear in the
year 20
right because estimates kept getting
smaller and smaller for the size of
pluto
it became completely clear that pluto
did not have the chops to be responsible
for the perturbations on uranus and
neptune
[Music]
wait a minute let's let's let's not
forget that part of history where
neil degrasse tyson comes along and then
pluto is just dissed and demoted
and implicating me i was an accessory
first of all
and this explainer video ain't got
nothing to do with that okay
so don't be dragging that in and making
people angry on the comment thread
chuck i thought you were my friend
[Laughter]
without having to be historically
complete okay
okay go ahead planet x was not really
there
that pluto was was not solving the
planet x problem right
okay plus we had looked where the
mathematician said
it should be and it wasn't and pluto was
found somewhere else
but the excitement of having found
planet x
carried the day okay it still didn't
solve the uranus neptune problem
it took till 1993. oh my god
okay and what do we have by then we have
excellent mass measurements for uranus
and neptune from the
from the voyager flybys we have
excellent mass
measures of of other objects pluto's
mask as better known
and so we know more about the mass
tugging that's going on in the outer
solar system
and a guy named miles standish jr
working for the jet propulsion lab
said let me try to resolve this once and
for all so he looks at the orbits of
uranus and neptune
it looks at how much they're being
perturbed and said well we looked there
we didn't find anything well let me go
back to the data
and here's what he found that between
1895 and 1905 the u.s
naval observatory that's in
right outside of dc might be in dc the
us naval observatory
had a set of data on the orbits of
uranus and neptune
that were kind of different from other
data that was out there
and then he wondered well did they clean
the gearbox over that time does
something different happen there
or did it get gunked up so he said let
me just
excise that 10 years of data from that
observatory from this analysis
when he did that all other orbital data
from all other historical telescopes
fell right into place and boom
planet x evaporated overnight
oh my god so he killed planet x
he killed planet x by discovering faulty
data
right so all the other data lined up
because that data was twerking the other
data
right twerking not twerking twerking it
torquing the other data
if you're trying to fit it and
something's tugging on it
and you think something's tugging on it
when in fact it was just simply bad
data and then milestones had the right
wherewithal he's a scientist right to
say let me see what happens
if i remove it and he does it all
planets line up
newton's laws are intact there is no
planet x
all is well in mudville that is amazing
so
the first time it's if herschel thinks
it's a comic
second time it's the triumph of newton's
laws right
third time it's faulty data right
okay and you don't know any of this
advance you just sort of
you're wandering in the dark because
you're at the limits of human
understanding
of the universe but wait my story is not
over
uh oh what happens in the late 1800s
we're looking at mercury's orbit and
mercury now okay and we find out that
you know it's an ellipse and the ellipse
is not
staying stationary in space it's
actually the ellipse itself
is rotating so in other words there's
mercury going around the sun and there's
a closest point to the sun
you wait till the next orbit that
closest point has actually rotated a
little bit
okay the closest point rotated again so
the ellipse is actually
dancing around the sun in a way that
cannot be accounted for by newton's laws
can't explain it well we've been down
that road before
right it's a it's a planet okay where's
my standards when you need them
okay no no but then that would be the
errors right so we had good enough data
we know there were no errors in these
measurements
oh that's right okay okay so
what could be causing this it's got to
be a planet come on we're we
we're experienced at this well how come
we haven't discovered it yet
it should be right in front of our nose
well because it's it's orbiting really
near the sun
and it's so near the sun it's blotted
out by the sunlight but it's tugging on
mercury
preventing mercury from following
newton's law so we astronomers were
perfectly happy with this we even had a
name for that planet
it's called vulcan okay so planet vulcan
was in the books we hadn't discovered it
yet but we knew it had to be there
just the same way your neptune was in
the dark skies
of uranus okay and there we were
then we said well if it's there and the
sun is too bright let's look during an
eclipse
right okay so every eclipse that came up
everyone comb the sky around the clips
no vulcan
no vocal they said well maybe was behind
the sun for every one of your eclipses
i don't think so i don't know okay so
you know what happens 1916 happens
albert einstein invents discovers the
general theory of relativity which is an
extension of newton's laws of gravity
for very high sources of gravity such as
if you're near the sun
and what he discovered is that this
procession of mercury
falls right out of his equations
yes newton got it wrong in the presence
of high gravity
his laws fail and it required the new
and improved understanding of gravity
brought to us
by by uh that's right
the moral to the story is math is hard
sciences science is hard in one case
it's it's the laws are correct and you
make a prediction in another case
the law is still correct but there was
bad data in another case the law is
wrong
and you need a whole other theory of
physics to explain it
i'm just trying to get you to understand
and appreciate appreciate
it no i love it because and here's i
know we're
over time but i just got to say this the
beauty of this
story is science is a journey
it is not a destination yes and
at all times at all times it's a journey
and you got to be open to any
possibility you got to be
open to the possibility that your
comment might be a planet that no one
has ever discovered before
you got to be open to the possibility
that somebody's data sucks you gotta be
open to the possibility that the power
of your math
and laws of physics are genuine and can
actually extend your understanding of
the universe
and you gotta be open to the fact that
you might have already reached the
limits of the applicability of your
theories and laws and you need a whole
new one such as what einstein put on the
table
and chuck that's why science is hard
sweet we gotta cut it quits there ah
okay all right this has been
the science is hard explainer chuck
always good to have you
always a pleasure to be here as always
you